i wish there were some customers here
i can't believe i just said that
ooh nice assist i played basketball when
i was a kid until my parents let me stop
okay hey check it out moving target oh
bring it on
three points okay hey oh
yeah in your face brett three
two one muffin ball
into the mop bucket yes that's a niner
he's looking a tenant
oh oh you guys
are you literally insane sorry mateo
could you throw us back the muffin bowl
though
i could but i won't hey yo you know what
we should get blockers i was just gonna
say that hey thanks mateo
i'm having a lot of fun with you don't
ever say that to me again
just get the blockers there all right
marcus now they ooped me into the cooler
okay guys
come back come back damn it he's got the
moves left yeah
mateo tattles me that you're playing a
game instead of working
seriously dude yeah you're misusing
baked goods and hurting people's
cashmere stuff come on man i'm sorry but
this game is over okay i'm throwing this
away
oh did you see that what glenn you just
got
a mannequin bumper is that good
i don't know is the best you can do good
come on you had to play this before no i
swear
i mean i'm on my church's wiffle ball
team well i i get the emails
ooh well i don't know i mean i'd say
you're a nasty i mean that was
incredible
mm-hmm glenn they're obviously
manipulating you you're just jealous
because i got a mani bump on my first
try
please anyone can hit that stupid
mannequin really prove it
oh nice matteo i did it
yeah you did i'm an athlete athlete
i did it i'm simone biles i'm simone
bile
yes olympic gymnast
loose muffin loose muffin yeah
[Music]
excuse me where are the paper towels i'm
sorry i don't think we sell those here
i can see the whole store from up here
oh
no it's gonna be
you